And everybody, this is November 8th and we're heading for winter here in Christmas time.
So we are jumping on our next Zoom call.
So today's Zoom call is going to be on some topics that people had said to do about what
they wanted, some questions answered.
So remember, if you have questions that you want answered and you want me to address on a
Zoom call that you think would might be appropriate for everybody else to hear too, then just
make sure you ask me on the Facebook page or you can email the clinic and they'll get
that information to me or you can call the office and tell them that you want something
addressed on a Zoom call.
Okay, so today's questions were some of what the right machine, so we're going to start
with that.
So the right machine using the right machine during the day, is it possible to get too much
right feed?
What should we do during the day if we can do the right machine during the day?
So again, let's stand back to originally my, you know, base philosophy is on what people
do in the right treatment at night while they're sleeping, so they don't have to do it during
the day.
They're certainly getting a lot of right time while you're sleeping.
But if you are not ambulatory for whatever reason, you're in bed, you're getting other treatment,
you're doing chemotherapy, you're doing some other therapy or even rest either sitting
and watching a movie, that's where I tell people to set up a, make your bedroom kind
of a sanctuary for yourself to be able to rife at different times if you're going to sit
and watch a movie or sit and watch a football game or read a book, you go to your bedroom
and do some other rife programming.
Now, if you request to me, I will write some specific programs, some short programs to you
and I can send it to you on a flash drive.
So just make that request to me, but there are thousands of programs on your rife machine
already that may be very appropriate for you to run.
In the normalizing, a folder that's titled normalizing frequencies, there's numerous different
programs that I like.
What is the accelerated healing program?
What is the DNA repair program?
What is the detox and lymph program?
And I would challenge you to just go through the alphabetical list of the programs that are
on your rife.
And if any of them jump out at you, that boy, I should run this.
This looks interesting, run that program.
Some of the programs are just a couple of minutes long, some of the programs are a couple of hours
long, but most of them range in the 30 to 90 minute range.
So another question is, do I have to run the whole program to have the effect of it?
No, you're running frequencies.
So you can run just a piece of a program, depending on how much time you have, run that piece
of that program.
The other thing you can do during the day is you can run your night program during the
day.
So you can run that twice a day.
That is certainly a good mix of different frequencies that are set up specifically for you and
for your cancer or for your Lyme or whatever you're dealing with.
So there's nothing wrong with running that Sunday night program, Sunday during the day
as well.
That might be the easiest thing to do, especially if you are expecting that you're going
to have a long time sitting there.
So many times, I have patients that are done ambulatory, they're in a hospital bed in
the middle of the limit room, and I'll set up programs where they're basically running
the RIF 24-7, which answers the question, can a person get too much rified?
Well, the only time you can get too much rified is if you're trying to kill Lyme disease,
you could overdose on the RIF because you could kill the Lyme bacteria too quickly and
again, the bacteria in Lyme, the Borrelia, and its co-infections.
Most of them are gram-negative bacteria that will liberate lipopolysaccharides, which was
stimulated immune response, and if you're autoimmune, we don't want to do that.
So you can do too much rified if you're running kill programs, if you have Lyme disease.
You cannot, you cannot, you cannot, you cannot do too much rified if you have cancer.
Now, if you have Lyme disease, you could run other done kill programs during the day that
will not stimulate the immune response, but just make sure you check with me about that.
So you have a wonderful tool with the rifishade, and I hate to see people not use it.
So you're not going to burn out the bulb, you're not going to burn out the machine, you use
the machine, and use it all the time.
Your family should use the machine, if you're not using it, your kids, your grandkids using
the machine, just, that should be your go-to for every disease.
We often get calls that, oh, I have really a bad cold.
What should I run on the RIF?
We'll just look up alphabetically on that list, start familiarizing yourself with the other
programs that are on your machine, there's well over 1,000 programs on your machine.
So start scrolling down that list, looking at the individual folders.
The only thing that you have to be cautious about is remember, you got that bulb bath setting.
If you're running anything with a bulb plugged in, which is your hammer bulb, you have to
have it on the bulb setting.
There is a folder that is for the bath program, or the bath is a totally different apparatus.
Some of you have it, some of you don't.
It plugs in here in the machine.
This machine has a grown plug in this picture.
We don't use this grown, and it's almost not used for anybody anymore.
But that's where the bath with apparatus will be plugged in, and that goes into the bath
water, and then you switch this to bath, and then you're running the bath programs.
Ion Pro Wave, if you want to purchase that, you can purchase it directly from us.
We have them in the office, we sell them at cost.
So that is a good way to detoxify, and it's another tool to detoxify and pull stuff through
the skin at your feet.
But don't run the Ion Pro Wave programs that are supposed to be run on the bath apparatus
with the bulb.
That would be the only other caution.
And it does say so on all those Ion Pro Wave programs.
This is to only be run with the bath.
And vice versa, you don't run the Ion Pro Wave programs with the bulb.
So you don't run the bulb programs with the Ion Pro Wave programs with the bulb.
But otherwise, look through those folders, and you can run any of those other programs.
Another good folder that I like on there is the depression set.
The depression set is seven days of about two hour programs for depression.
But they're really not just for depression.
It's really good for all sorts of just mood issues, and just anxiety can be really helpful
for that too.
So I challenge you to use that as well.
The next program, the next questions we had were on lymphatic drainage.
And especially if you've had surgery to remove a tumor or surgery of any kind, you may have
had lymphatic nodes removed.
So your lymphatic system, again, is the way your body drains the extra cellular spaces.
So you have a vascular system that uses a heart as a pump to pump blood through the vessels
and that it recirculates through the veins to re-oxygenate, to gain nutrition and then
back through the heart, through the arteries to feed the body.
Now think of that.
So red blood cells feed the tissue with oxygen, nutrients pass through the capillary walls,
get into the tissues, get into the cells.
In order for the cells to do all their function, and the cells produce waste, and outside of
the cell membranes, waste is expelled, and that waste has to be carried away somehow.
It does not go back into the blood system.
How does that waste get carried away?
Well, you have these open-ended capillaries called your lymphatic capillaries.
Think of them as storm sewers on a street.
So you have storm sewers so that when it rains, the water runs down into the storm sewer down
the pipes.
Well, that's kind of like your lymphatic system.
These open-ended capillaries that drain back to larger vessels, lymphatic vessels, through
lymph nodes, and lymph nodes are part of your immune system.
They have a lot of T lymphocytes and macrophages to kill any bacteria or viruses or pathogens
that are traveling through the lymphatic system because it's all waste.
So think of what could go through a storm sewer, it's a lot of garbage.
Well, that's really what's draining back from your cells and from the spaces between the
cells called the extracellular spaces is a lot of garbage.
And so you have this capillary system that's bringing that back.
So the lymph nodes are very important in order to drain that area so that you have healthy
tissue.
And if you have your lymph nodes removed, well, then you could have a greater risk of having
lymph stasis because you're removing where these lymph vessels have to drain to.
And you could have lymph stasis meeting that it's like you're the storm sewers getting stuffed
with leaves, then where is this when we have a torrential downpour or a five day steady
rain, which your cells are constantly giving off waste, where is that waste going to go,
and that lymph stasis is going to be seed as swelling.
So if you had lymph nodes removed in this area for breast cancer, you have a greater risk
of lymph stasis in this arm, and you could have, you could measure a larger arm here because
you got swelling in here.
So what are some things you could do to help with lymph stasis?
Even if you didn't have surgery, you could have lymph stasis because of other reasons.
If you had any injury, you could have scar tissue and that could clamp down on the lymph vessels.
And if the, understand the lymph system doesn't have a heart that pumps this through.
So if you're sedentary for any reason, you're tired, you're fatigued, you're not getting
out of bed as much, you're not exercising.
So without the action of contraction of the muscles that's actually physically squeezing these
lymph vessels and pushing the waste through the lymph vessels, you could get lymph stasis.
Inside the lymph vessels, you have valves that go one way.
So the valves open up to let the fluid go through, when you contract a muscle, and then they close
so the fluid doesn't go backwards.
So it's allowing that lymph to travel in this direction to get back to the main lymph nodes
to that drain to the bloodstream and then to the liver and then to the kidneys and out of your body.
So there's different techniques to help with lymph stasis.
Now the number one thing that helps lymph flow, I already mentioned, it's muscle contraction.
So if you don't have muscle contraction, you have a greater risk of lymph stasis, but there's a
bunch of other tools that you could do. So in your manual, in your binder, you have a bunch of these
things in behind the diet part of your manual before you get to the, it's in the first section of your
manual at the back of that first section. There's dry brushing techniques. There's a vibratory
plates. These vib plates are really good, they're really good for your brain too, but they're really good.
If you stand at these vib plates, they could really help you move lymph because they stimulate your
muscles to microcontract. So that contraction of the muscles helps move lymph. The PEMF is a good
lymph tool. This machine here is used to be really big on the market a number of years back. It's
called a chi machine. You lay down on the floor, you put your ankles in this and it goes back and forth
and back and forth. And if you don't have a low back condition, it's actually quite comfortable,
very relaxing. You just want to, they're very readily available on the market on Amazon though. You
just want to get one that has good, you know, a larger base like this one does. There's some cheaper ones
with a skinnier base. And I'll just tell you, I've had them and they just hurt your ankles and you
you don't want to do it. So this one has more of a rubber base and you can even put a towel in there.
But you need it deep enough so your ankles aren't folded out of them. But these are very comfortable
to relax you as long as you don't have a low back condition. Laser, Class 4 laser is wonderful for
lymphatic motion. That's a big key component of that. A lot of people ask about can I do a lymphatic
massage is that is that okay for me is that too much. The thing I caution you about the weight of
massages, if you've never had massages, you've got to go really slow. And you don't want a massage
right by the sight of a cancer. That would be the second caution. And when I say go slow on a
massage, don't let somebody do a deep tissue massage on you if you've never had deep tissue massage.
You're going to push your road a lot of toxins. And if you have had surgery where they've removed
lymph nodes, there's there'd be difficult for them to find a place to go. So you there is a
technique massage therapy that many massage therapists have been traded in a lymphatic
what's called lymphatic massage. Most massage therapists know how to do this. But you're massaging
in the direction of the lymph nodes. So you'd be massaging in the direction of where you want
to live to flow. So you're moving in that direction. A lymphatic massage is a little bit different
than a deep tissue massage. But again, there's a bunch of different massage therapists that have had
some to little trading too. So you want to go to somebody who has had trading. I used to have a
massage therapist on staff that actually was traded in cancer massages. So there is trading available
in that. And that was some years ago. So there's probably even better trading today. But helping
the helping the waist move back towards the heart is what you want to do typically in a lymphatic
drainage massage. But again, I caution you to be careful because you can stir up a lot of toxins
in the tissue that just make it harder on your body and you could feel really sick afterwards.
And I will testify to that personally. So these are just some different techniques to get
lived going. Another real good technique that's not really a lymphatic drainage technique,
but it helps get rid of toxins. What a person does have, let's say, go back to an example,
have a breast surgery with removing a bunch of lymph nodes. And you have stasis to the arm here is
doing infrared sodas. So doing a soda can be really helpful because you're helping your body detox
other than going through the lymphatic system that brings it back to the blood vessels that brings
it back to the liver or the kidney. So you're bypassing the liver and the kidney and helping you
use your skin as an organ of detoxification through a soda. But again, if you've never used a soda,
you got to go slow on that and you're going to build up time. And many people can't sweat in a soda
because they've just never done that before. So sometimes it takes a person some time doing
soda to be able to really be able to sweat like a pig like I say in a soda. You want to do that.
You want to sweat excessively in a soda. If you're going to do a soda that no, that brings up
other questions about, oh, do I need to make sure I've added electrolytes because you will sweat out
a lot of tissue salts when you sweat. So if you're doing a soda a couple times a week,
your diet is probably plenty adequate to handle any electrolytes you're losing. But if you're doing
a soda in a half hour a day, we may need to add electrolytes to your diet as well. And remember,
electrolytes are just minerals, salts in minerals. So maybe some pig salt, maybe some multibids would be
in order if you're doing daily sodas. The other question that we had were just on lifestyle questions
and we go back to this chart. And I told my staff that sometimes I think, oh, I've already shared
about this thing. So I don't want to share about it again, but I forget that not everybody thinks
the same way I do and thinks about these things 24-7. So I need to hit some of these
things again. So lifestyle factors that affect this pathway, this pathway, this mTOR pathway is
critically important with those that have cancer. So we do not want to stimulate or excessively
stimulate. You can't help but stimulate the mTOR pathway. That's how your body heals. But we don't
want to add any extra burden of stimulation to our mTOR pathway. And the mTOR pathway is a
genetic pathway that creates an enzyme that stimulates healing. So what the mTOR does, you look at
follow the arrows, it stimulates messenger RNA translation, which is how your cells replicate
and how you're... we don't want to do that with cancer patients, right? It stimulates
aerobic glycolysis, which that's what most cancers are already feeding off of is aerobic glycolysis.
That's the best way in order to make energy is aerobic glycolysis. Well, we don't want to stimulate
that in a cancer patient. Stimulates lipid synthesis and fatty acid cycle pathway energy production.
Pentose phosphate pathway, that's energy production as well, nucleotide synthesis, that's how you
replicate cells. So these are all great things to have if we're growing. These are great things to
have if I'm trying to build muscle, if I'm going for a workout and I want to get stronger and build
muscle, if I'm healing from an injury, if I'm growing as a child, these are all things that you want
to take place. So that's why I've said multiple places that if I'm dealing with a heart condition,
and I want new tissue to grow, then I want to stimulate mTOR function. If I'm dealing with
trying to stay, you know, anti-aging protocol for a patient, I want to stimulate mTOR function.
If I'm dealing with cancer, it's a totally different ballgame. We don't want to stimulate
mTOR function in that cancer. So the way we would treat some diseases is very different than
the way we would want to treat a cancer patient. So in a cancer patient, we don't want to stimulate
mTOR function. All these things in the grid here are things that stimulate mTOR function. Now if
you start thinking through these, they make a lot of sense. So amino acids, so I eat a lot of amino
acids. It stimulates mTOR function. That's what a body builder would do. We're going to eat a lot of
meat. We're going to eat a lot of proteins because we're willing to build muscles.
Hormone function. So when what our body goes through and build up of hormones, we stimulate mTOR,
and our body starts changing. IGF-1 function has to do with healing injuries and healing wounds.
Also has to do with a young person growing. So in childhood, we have a high IGF-1 function.
It stimulates mTOR. We eat sugar. We stimulate insulin production by the pancreas. We stimulate
mTOR. We increase iron in our diet. We stimulate mTOR. That's why iron may not be a good idea for most
cancer patients. It's iodine, which is an amino acid, again, in SAME, which these are very
important to the methionine cycle when we look at your genetics, but too much of it stimulates mTOR.
Glutamates, we have done that on a weekly basis. I do at least because it's the number one thing that
stimulates mTOR. Using folate, I get this all the time and we need to have a discussion maybe next week
just on that because there's a giant fad today about the MTHFR gene. So the MTHFR gene, there's
even Facebook groups of MTHFR Facebook group, and I can't even look at the post because I used to
post out there and tell people the truth that I just got tired. I feel like I was begging my head
against the wall, but there's people absolutely completely obsessed with the MTHFR gene. And it's
mainly because of practitioners that are giving very, very false information. So sometimes it's
dangerous when you know just a little bit about something. So I have a lot of patients that are taking a
lot of folate or a methyl tetrahydropholate product, or any methylated B12 methyl comolamine.
That will stimulate mTOR. So we've got to be careful on how much we use of that. A little bit
for a cancer patient can be just fine. Too much can really stimulate mTOR. So cytokines, this
what's happens, the cytokine is a type of chemical that's made by the immune system.
In the place of a chronic infection usually a person has a ramped up TH1 cytokines in a
chronic infection and stimulates mTOR. And that's why biotoxins, some clinical, long-term,
some clinical media, not really symptomatic chronic infection like H. Pylori or even Lyme disease
can be a major cause for cancer. So monkey genes themselves. So there's different genes when we look
at your genes that are what are called oncogenes because they actually have those genes,
those defects actually can stimulate cancer. So these are first discovered. They thought they
found the cause of cancer, but they found now it's known that oncogenes are the cause of cancer,
but they're just another piece that can stimulate mTOR that can increase the rate of cancer replication
if you have cancer. So these in themselves aren't necessarily causes of cancer, but these are
participants. It increase the rate of cancer growth in a person that has cancer. So that's the important
thing we've got. So that's why we take people with people at a limited area and limit their protein
consumption. Stay away from plastic, stay away from cell phone towers at EMF. So look at that,
no high fructose corn syrup, no higher than rich foods, no methyl products, glutamate, glutamate,
MSG, bone broth, pesticides. So that's why I do make these recommendations and it's good to how
does this once in a while because sometimes we forget that we start slacking on our diet and everything,
that's not a good thing. But if you know why you're doing something it can give you some ammunition
to stay the course. All right, does anybody have any questions about this or anything else I
didn't use anybody? So feel free to speak up. All right, we are at our end. Make sure that you
email any questions that you have for next week. We are going to be Wednesday again next week and
it's the same link again. So remember it's always the same link. And we will have this posted on
Facebook in a very short time. Thanks.